[Music]  hi my name is emmy eaton my favorite  thing to do in  my hometown idaho  is i like potatoes and then eat them  there are more than a million potatoes  made each day yummy yummy yummy except i  don't like it when they're all dirty we  walked into the room where there were a  bunch of potatoes and there was like a  conveyor belt that was holding up like  the potatoes it shot water everywhere in  there and then we got to the big stack  of potatoes they have to wait one year  in the big like room they have to keep  it nice and cool so like there's fans  everywhere  and stuff because they don't want it to  go rotten and moldy  because that's gross  [Music]  you